[Musique]
bonjour bertrand françois l'humain
bonjour bonjour auditrices et aux
auditeurs de martinique 1ère
universitaire docteur en droit public et
officiant à l'université des antilles
c'est le jour j c'est le jour j
-françois monsieur françois lui bien
pour les candidats à la présidentielle
française puisque tout à l'heure 13
heures heure de fort de france
le conseil constitutionnel va clôturer
le dépôt des parrainages et
manifestement on va vers 8 peut être
neuf candidats pour cette présidentielle
oui comme vous venez de le dire c'est la
date limite donc de clôture dont le
recueil des candidats des candidats donc
qui ont ce qu'ils ont manifesté en tout
cas l'intention de se présenter aux
suffrages des français
le trait avait déjà pour le le 23/09 23
avril pour le premier tour alors
effectivement donc h et à 18 heures
heure métropole de la métropole et 13
heures chez nous nous aurons donc une
idée donc de la liste de ceux qui vont
pouvoir concourir à cette élection et
demain
à 11h30 dans coeur de l'hexagone le
conseil constitionnel va faire un point
de presse
et rendre publique la liste donc de ceux
qui vont se présenter aux suffrages des
français à un moment bertras fort sur
lui bien on a eu jusqu'à 70 intentions
de candidature pour cette présidentielle
je n'avais revendre oui je vous en ai
senti à un moment donné enfin 817 mais
bon les chutes choses se sont un peu je
dirais décanter ces derniers temps
puisque pour l'instant il ya que 49
candidats qui apparaissent clairement
sur le site du conseil constitutionnel
il ya des choses qui ont changé un les
modalités de parrainage ce qui a quand
même provoqué quelques remous puisque
certains maires de toutes petites
communes ont quelque peu fait la grève
des parrainages
oui alors on peut dire qu'à l'occasion
donc de cette élection présidentielle
prochaine on verra
apparaître un nouveau droit je dirais
des élections présidentielles puisque il
ya deux textes fondamentaux qui ont été
adoptées
dernièrement donc en octobre 2013 et en
avril 2016 qui ont un peu modernisée
notamment les règles de présentation des
candidats et en l'occurrence donc la
règle qui s'applique des hommes et qui
s'est appliqué à l'occasion consistant
pour l'essentiel à protéger les petits
élus contre toute forme de pression
puisque ces derniers alors l'écart en
2001 pour ce qu'ils sont quarante deux
mille personnes habilitées à parrainer
ce qui se présente à cette élection et
donc devrait remplir un formulaire pré
établis et l'adresser au conseil
communal par voie postale
oui mais il faudrait quand même des
petits meyrin parce qu'il la redoute la
pression de leurs deux de leurs
habitants oui mais bon ce sont libres de
choisir mais en tout cas l'intention
affichée à travers cette nouvelle
méthode était justement consisté à les
protéger
de sorte que haineux n'avait pas à
recevoir les représentants des
différents candidats
on va entrer dans le vif du sujet à
partir de demain 11 heures 30 avec cette
campagne des notions qu'il faut encore
et toujours réexpliqué confort soit
lui-même la stricte égalité sur l'étang
campagne durant la campagne officielle
et surtout les quitter en attendant
d'accord alors pour il ya deux périodes
qu'il faut distinguer alors bon en fait
il y en avait trois bon je vais résonner
ce qui est possible désormais à partir
du moment où la liste des candidats sera
établi alors cette période qu'on appelle
la période de précampagne qui va
commencer donc on va dire aujourd'hui
voire demain mais de manière plus
officielle la semaine prochaine puisque
la liste des candidats sera publié au
journal officiel donc ça devrait être le
dis probablement alors à partir de cette
date jusqu'au 10 avril
la recommandation qui est faite au csa
aux stations de radio et télévision donc
s'agisse pour ses prochaines élections
qui dessert consiste à favoriser un
accès équitable de tous ceux dont de
tous ceux qui ont vocation à figurer sur
la liste aux antennes des radios et
télévisions alors ça fait grincer des
dents
notion d'équité dans les salles c'est le
nez le tout premier débat présidentiel
sur le tf par exemple abeilles y en a
qui sont exclus et qui ne et qui ne sont
pas contents ils le font savoir
oui alors pas plus tard qu'hier je crois
comme ceux dupont-aignan s'est plaint
auprès du conseil d'état de ne pas
pouvoir être présent à la à l'émission
qui est programmée lundi soir sur les
antennes de tf1 alors en l'occurrence le
csa ca à propos pouvoir apprécier donc
ce traitement équitable de l'ensemble
des candidats s'appuie sur deux critères
d'abord la question de la
représentativité des candidats alors en
d'autres termes il s'agit de on va se
référer aux résultats de tous les
candidats à l'occasion des élections qui
se sont déroulées depuis les dernières
élections présidentielles ça c'est le
premier critère sur lequel le csa puis
ou encore les sondages quels sont ceux
qui sont récemment dans les nouveaux
épisodes ça siffle autres les sondages
alors je vous dise que ce sur quoi le
csa puis le deuxième élément c'est la
capacité pour chacun de manifester sa
volonté donc de se présenter allons
notamment dochia de quelques éléments
qui sont retenus à cet effet par exemple
la désignation d'un mandataire financier
ou encore l'organisation de réunions
publiques le des visites sur le terrain
ce sont autant d'éléments sur lesquels
le csa va s'appuyer pour se prononcer
sur la question de l'accès équitable
donc de tous les candidats aux stations
de radio télévision jusqu'au 10 avril
et à partir du 10 avril qui est le qui
va marquer le début de la campagne
officielle à la seconde près quand on
devrait alors là on va rentrer dans un
autre registre il va falloir que les
stations de radio et télévision traite
également à la seconde rené plus dans
l'équité traite également l'ensemble des
candidats comment quand même de la
primaire à droite comme à gauche
est ce que les choses peuvent reste en
l'état tous derrière le vainqueur ça
c'est pas franchement gagnants devront
encore ou bien une victoire lors de ces
primaires qui donnerait une légitimité
une légitimité difficile à remettre en
cause en cas de souci par la suite là
encore on est dans l'actualité
est ce que ce système de primaires peut
encore perdurer
alors c'est bien la preuve qu'un outil
n'est pas parfait en soi alors parce que
a priori les primaires constituent
certainement un instrument je dirais
idoine pour donner pour permettre une
expression démocratique
mais sauf qu'à l'usagé on se peut se
poser dans cette nombre de questions
après ce qui s'est passé je dirais aux
états unis dans le cadre de la primaire
de la droite et la primaire de la gauche
qu'est ce qu'on constate on constate que
l'ensemble des candidats ont une
tendance à surenchérir pour sortir
vainqueur et qu'après on constate donc
par ailleurs un recentrement des
propositions donc il ya décalage
manifeste entre que ce qu'on a pu dire à
l'occasion donc des primaires est ce que
le candidat propose par la suite aux
électeurs et on le voit bien notamment
pour françois ramon encore que celui ci
lors de la présentation de ceux de son
programme hier c'est un peu gauchisé
mais à un moment donné il ya eu un
flottement puisqu'elle a dû il a eu des
démos qui tendait à lens et qui tendrait
à laisser à penser que il nous revenait
ce roi centre est donc ces propositions
son discours pourtant ces primaires
lorsqu'on regarde les attentions doit
aujourd'hui un bain les deux qui sont
devant ben ce sont des candidats aux
primaires
nguyen mais c'est aussi oui alors quand
vous tout à l'heure vous disiez que vous
parliez des sondages
effectivement il faut qu'on apprenne à
raison garder s'agissant des sondages
puisque là encore les prix mais à la
froid aux états unis des républicains ou
encore de la gauche tendait à montrer
qu'il y avait des candidats pour ramer
des vainqueurs pour ramer sauf que les
électeurs les citoyens se sont prononcés
autrement très rapidement parce qu'il
resterait très peu de temps pour
l'instant c'est marine le pen candidat
du front national du caracole en tête
est-ce que vous avez l'impression vous
en tant que professeur en tant
qu'observateur de ce qui se passe sur le
plan politique
est ce que vous avez l'impression que le
message frontistes se répand ici en
martinique alors
je n'ai pas d'éléments statistiques me
permettant donc de d'attester ce que
vous dites mais bon intuitivement oui on
se rend compte personnellement j'en
compte des gens qui me disent qu'ils
sont prêts à voter marine le pen ne
souhaite qu'un argument qui interpelle
pour le moins on a tout essayé et ses
toiles enfin voilà pourquoi ne pas lui
donner sa chance bon ce sont des
arguments qui sont à saint-herblain en
tout cas au delà du cas française qu'on
peut ce qui est surtout manifeste c'est
qu'il ya un contexte favorable à la
montée en flèche donc des partis
d'extrême droite
on a vu donc bien s'en est fallu de peu
pour que le candidat de l'extrême doit
gagnent les élections en pays bas et on
voit bien que partout donc en europe
notamment iliad monte donc en puissance
donc des partis d'extrême droite dans un
contexte marqué par la crise économique
et sociale et la défiance à l'endroit de
ce qu'on appelle les partis de
gouvernement
merci d'avoir été avec nos bertrand
françois leblanc rappelle que vous êtes
docteur en droit public et et enseignant
à l'université des antilles merci
d'avoir été avec tout son matériel dans
son caddie
[Musique]
ex